[Music]
i know what this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart i am smart
i know okay okay
[Music]
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
[Music]
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
mommy i need your unique low-key
perspective
do i get a weapon yeah
you really believe in this loki variant
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
it is adorable that you think you could
possibly
manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can't trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
why never do it again
[Music]
get your hands on
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you're taking me somewhere to kill me no
i'm taking you someplace to talk
well i don't like to talk but you do
like to lie which you
just did because we both know you
love to talk
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say you know time passes
differently here in the tva what does
that mean
you'll catch up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
glorious
so
brother i'm down
you'd better be ready
come on what did you expect
[Music]
you